Il y a beaucoup d'actu chez Honor. Je vous ai
parlé il y a quelques jours du Honor 9X
Pro. Je vous avais parlé il y a
quelques mois du Honor 9X. Sur l'ancien modèle il y
a les services Google, le nouveau ne
les a pas. Il y a l'AppGallery. Allez voir
les vidéos pour tout savoir sur les nouveautés
de Honor. Je vous ai également
parlé de la Honor MagicWatch 2 modèle
46 mm. C'est leur dernière montre connectée.
Aujourd'hui, on va parler d'un
nouveau produit de Honor. C'est celui là.
Honor arrive dans l'univers du PC en Europe
avec le Honor MagicBook 14 pouces.
Il existe en version 14 pouces et 15
pouces. Ici, J'ai le 14 pouces. Est-ce
que Honor a réussi son arrivée en Europe
dans l'univers des PC ? Le marché est déjà
saturé, mais Honor fait une proposition
qui est assez intéressante. Je vais tout
de suite commencer par le tarif. Le tarif
est à 599,90 euros. Il y a des offres
spéciales sur le site de Honor
France, mais également sur Amazon.
Je vous le détaillerai à la fin de la vidéo.
Pendant le confinement je vous ai
demander de m'envoyer vos vidéos de chez
vous pour savoir comment ça se passait
chez vous à l'email qui s'affiche ici.
amour@monsieurgrrr.fr On va donc visionner
la vidéo du jour. Salut à tous
et à toutes. Je me nomme Zayel Mohamed
d'origine comorienne. En ce moment je me
trouve au Maroc. Ça fait trois semaines
qu'on est confiné. Je faisais un petit
coucou à Monsieur GRrr. Restez chez
vous et sauver des vies. Je laisse
Monsieur GRrr nous présenter un bon
produit. Merci pour cette vidéo.
Parlons du Honor MagicBook 14 pouces. Est-il fait
pour vous? Quels sont ses points
positifs ? Ses points négatifs ? Quelles sont ses
limites? Que peut-on faire avec ? A
qui se destine-t-il? Faut-il l'acheter? Vers
le logo Honor il y a du bleu qui
apparait. C'est très esthétique et j'aime beaucoup.
Il y a également un liseré bleu qui
fait tout le tour du produit . Sinon le design
est assez simple. Le gris est très
classique. En dessous il y a une grille
de ventilation. On devine le ventilateur.
Les haut-parleurs se trouvent ici.
Les petits patins là. Je vais
détailler la connectique dans quelques instants.
Vous pouvez l'ouvrir à 180 degrés.
Quel intérêt me direz-vous? Je ne sais pas.
Il est très léger. Il pèse 1,38
kilo. Son châssis est en aluminium. Il existe
en deux couleurs Mystic Silver et Space
Grey. Le bouton d'alimentation inclus
un capteur d'empreintes digitales et déverrouille
très rapidement. La partie
design est très bien réussie. Est-ce
la même chose pour l'écran ? Il a un écran
LCD 14 pouces résolution Full HD 1920
par 1080px, avec une densité de pixels de 157
pixels par pouce. Un écran au format
16:9 avec un angle de vision de 178 degrés.
Pour avoir la meilleure position il faut
être face à l'écran. Si vous vous décalez
sur le côté, la qualité est moins
bonne. Vous verrez quand même mais ce n'est pas
optimal. Le mieux est d'être assis
face à l'écran. L'écran est certifié lutter
contre la lumière bleue. Il a
une luminosité maximale de 250 nits.
L'écran ne sera pas très lumineux
lorsque vous l'utiliserez en extérieur avec
beaucoup lumière. En intérieur c'est
idéal. Il a des bords qui sont très fins.
En bas le bord plus large. La webcam
n'est pas située en haut. Elle est intégrée dans
le clavier. C'est bien pour la sécurité.
Vous appuyez et elle disparaît. Le point
négatif c'est que vous êtes filmé
par dessous. Ce n'est pas esthétique.
C'est idéal pour voir les poils dans
votre nez. La caméra a 1 mégapixel. Elle n'a pas
la meilleure qualité, mais c'est
suffisant pour appeler des amis. La qualité
de l'écran est bien vu le prix de l'ordinateur.
La colorimétrie de l'écran
est un peu bleu. Si vous voulez faire
de retouche de photos, il faut le savoir.
Il est parfait pour de la bureautique.
Je vais vous l'expliquer dans quelques
instants. Qu'en est-il de la qualité
audio? Il a deux haut parleurs, le premier
haut parleur est ici, le deuxième
haut parleur est ici. Il a deux micros.
La qualité des haut parleurs n'est
pas extraordinaires. Voici un extrait audio.
Les fréquences aiguës
médiums-aigus et sont perdues au profit d'un sont
un étouffé médium-grave. Si vous montez
le son, ils vont saturer. Ce n'est pas
surprenant car il coûte moins de 600
euros. Pour écouter de la musique,
je vous conseille de brancher un casque.
Vous pouvez utiliser un casque sans fil
car il a du Bluetooth 5.0. La partie
performances? Il a un processeur AMD Ryzen
5 3500 U. Il a 8Go de RAM DDR4 à 2400
MHz. Il a un SSD de 256Go un peu plus rapide
que ce qu'on va pouvoir retrouver
usuellement. La capacité de stockage n'est
pas grande. Il n'a pas les meilleures
performances. J'ai perçu quelques
ralentissements. Les applications
mettent un peu de temps à s'ouvrir. Vous ne
jouerez pas à des jeux puissants.
Il sera idéal pour du contenu multimédia,
naviguer sur Internet, regarder des films.
Vous pourrez travailler, collaborer
et créer. Je vous déconseille les montages
vidéo à part des vidéos courtes de 4
minutes en FHD. Vous n'utiliserez
pas Photoshop avec pleins de calques.
Oubliez Lightroom. Votre PC serait
ralenti. La carte graphique est une Radeon
Vega 8. Il a une batterie de 56Wh.
Honor annonce une autonomie allant jusqu'à 10
heures en bureautique. Je n'ai atteint
10H d'autonomie. Il a tenu entre 6H et 6H30.
Cela dépendra de vos usages. De la luminosité
de votre écran. Des programmes
utilisés. L'autonomie va donc varier. Il a
un chargeur de 65 watts pour charger votre
PC rapidement. En 30 minutes de charge,
il gagnera quelques heures d'autonomie.
Pour une charge complète, il vous faudra
deux heures. Il fonctionne avec Windows 10
Home. Point intéressant : Honor
Magic Link qui fonctionne avec Huawei Share.
Honor fait partie du groupe Huawei.
Ils ont intégré cette technologie dans cet
ordinateur. Je vous fais une démonstration
avec le Huawei P40 Pro mais vous pouvez
choisir un smartphone récent de Honor.
Ouvrez PC Manager. Connectez votre
téléphone. Approchez-le. Il se
connecte. Votre smartphone apparaît sur votre PC.
Vous voyez vos applications. Vous pouvez
naviguer facilement. Envoyer un message.
Je peux envoyer une photo de mon
smartphone dans mon PC. Je pose mon
smartphone là et la photo est
envoyée dans mon ordinateur. Je peux partager
facilement des photos de mon
téléphone vers mon ordinateur, mais l'inverse est
aussi possible. Sur un fichier
Word ouvert, je pose mon smartphone.
Le document Word est transféré
directement dans mon smartphone. Je peux l'ouvrir
et l'éditer facilement. Cette fonction
fr partage est vraiment un +. L'écosystème
de Honor se concrétise de plus en plus.
La stratégie de Honor est identique à celle
Huawei. 1+8+n. 1 étant votre
smartphone, le coeur de l'écosystème.
L'objet technologique que vous avez
toujours avec vous. +8 ce sont
les différentes familles d'objets
connectés dont votre ordinateur fait
parti. Et N ce sont tous les produits
des collaborateurs tiers. Voila la stratégie
de Huawei et Honor en 2020. Il a un clavier
azerty avec une course de touches
un peu longue, mais qui ne pose pas
problème. Le trackpad est bien positionné.
Il a une bonne dimension par rapport à la taille
du châssis. La navigation est très
confortable. Une remarque vis à vis
des clics gauche et droit : si vous appuyez
fortement l'ensemble bouge et c'est
bizarre. Cette partie du châssis bouge
assez facilement. Il n'y a aucun
intérêt à venir appuyer ici. Mais il y a un rebond
qu'on vient retrouver ici. Rien
de problématique mais c'est surprenant.
À voir à l'usage, si des petites
choses peuvent venir s'introduire ici.
Je le trouve très réactif et il fonctionne
bien. Concernant la connectique : il y a
de l'USB-C, de l'USB 3.0, du HDMI,
mais également de l'USB 2.0 et une prise jack
3.5 pour brancher votre casque.
Vous pouvez brancher un moniteur externe
en HDMI. C'est une bonne chose. Ça aurait
été bien qu'il y ait 2 ports USB-C
puisque votre chargeur se connecte en USB-C.
Donc si vous le chargez, vous allez
occuper le port USB-C. Vous n'avez
donc pas pouvoir brancher un disque dur
externe, par exemple en USB-C. Il va
donc falloir attendre que votre ordinateur soit
chargé pour pouvoir le faire. Malgré
cela la connectique est complète. A qui se
destine cet ordinateur ? Honor est
une marque qui cible un public jeune.
Ils ciblent des étudiants, des jeunes
actifs. Des personnes qui veulent
un ordinateur cohérent qui vous permettra
de travailler et de faire
de la bureautique. De regarder
quelques films séries avec Netflix, YouTube ...
L'audio est en-deça, mais si vous utilisez
un casque, ça ira. Il n'est pas très
puissant mais pour jouer à des jeux.
Ce n'est pas un PC destiné aux créatifs qui
utilisent Photoshop, Première
... Ce n'est pas le PC qu'il vous faut.
Mais si vous voulez travailler
avec le pack Office, si vous voulez faire
du traitement de texte, gérer vos
emails. De la prise de notes si vous êtes
à la fac. Ou que vous voulez un PC
pour gérer le quotidien à la maison. Il peut
être fait pour vous, et à un bon
tarif. Il coûte 599,90 euros. Il y a des offres
intéressantes. Si vous voulez
l'acheter sur le site de Honor. D'ailleurs, il y a
un lien dans la description. Honor
vous offre la Honor MagicWatch 2 46 mm.
Elle coûte 199,90 euros. Cette
offre est valable jusqu'au 28 avril 2020.
Si vous voulez l'acheter chez Amazon,
vous n'avez pas de cadeau, mais par contre,
vous avez une offre de remboursement
de 100 euros jusqu'au 10 mai 2020.
Si il vous plait c'est le moment de l'acheter.
Vous trouverez les liens dans
la description. Si vous l'achetez
sur Amazon, vous ne la paierez pas 599,90€
mais 499,90€. Et si vous vouliez
vous acheter une montre connectée, allez sur
le site de Honor puisqu'ils vous offrent
une montre qui coûte presque 200€. Honor a
réussi son entrée dans le monde du PC
avec un ordinateur cohérent. Ce ne sera pas
le PC le + performant mais il sera
pour la bureautique. Comment vous le trouvez?
Dites-le moi en commentaire.
Êtes-vous tenté? Je vous embrasse et donne
rendez-vous demain. Ciao.